die oscar straße in dresden hier bauen
die städtischen verkehrsbetriebe eine
neue straßenbahntrasse samt anschluss an
die s bahn rund 20 millionen euro sollen
dafür investiert werden
doch weil eine landesbehörde bei der
planung böse geschlampt hat gibt es
jetzt ein gerichtlichen baustopp das
vorzeigeprojekt entwickelt sich zur
pleiten pech und pannen nummer für mich
unverständlich
nach jahrelangen vorbereitung wird seit
märz in der oskar straße gebaut doch
einige anwohner klagen gegen das
straßenbahnprojekt und tatsächlich
verhängt das oberverwaltungsgericht
bautzen einen baustopp denn der
verantwortlichen landesdirektion sachsen
ist ein gewaltiges juristisches
missgeschick passiert so die richter es
ist nicht nur eine lappalie es ist ein
schwerer verfahrensfehler passiert und
zwar bei der durchführung der
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung sie wurde
durchgeführt aber verfahrensrechtlich
nicht ordnungsgemäß die folge an der
straßenbahntrasse darf nicht
weitergebaut werden nur ein paar rohre
und versorgungsleitungen kommen noch in
die erde und danach wird's richtig
absurd die straße wird provisorisch neu
asphaltiert für mindestens 300.000 euro
von der verantwortlichen landesbehörde
will sich niemand vor der kamera äußern
kleinlaut räumt man ein die
landesdirektion sachsen bedauert dass es
zu formalen fehlern im
planfeststellungsverfahren gekommen ist
diese werden so schnell wie möglich im
rahmen eines planergänzungsverfahren
behoben
hoffentlich geht das nicht wieder in die
rose viele bürger in dresden schlagen
die hände über dem kopf zusammen
etwas was mächtig ins geld geht
vermischt und wieder stress ist ein
symptom in deutschland das
verwaltungsvorgänge durch formalien
verkompliziert werden herausgezögert und
teurer werden es ist nicht
nachvollziehbar und für uns als
steuerzahler überhaupt nicht vertretbar
aber einfach nur wut
wie in dresden wieder letztlich auch
steuergeld verschleudert wird
ach ja und wenn der schwere
verfahrensfehler behoben ist
dann wird die schön neu asphaltierte
straße wieder aufgerissen wann das
allerdings sein wird weiß derzeit keiner
so genau weil die unterlagen gerade erst
erarbeitet werden
für die baustellen der oscar straße
heißt es jedenfalls demnächst schicht im
schacht